it's time for scen and unseen where we
reveal the stories behind the headlines
for that we return to Fox News
contributor Raymond aroyo all right
Raymond we've been covering um Nikki
Haley's decision to stay in the race
with the plutocrats despite the polls
but you've discovered another indicator
of her
Effectiveness well well look Governor
Haley with great Fanfare at Laura
featured independent Judge Judy shinin
the other night at her New Hampshire
rally watch we need her and if we don't
have her it's going to be a tragedy for
this country I said to someone I would
vote for her if she were a
frog poor Nikki Haley It Ain't Easy
Being Green Laura but uh don't pay too
much attention to what people say you
know I always watch for what people do
and for all the effusive talk look
closely at Judge Judy look at her face
as she listens to Nikki Haley speak I
don't want all the political
establishment endorsements that
everybody's talking about you want those
that know what it's like to fight you
want those that know what it's like to
win and you want those that love our
country and it's not about them all
right Laura do you think she's buying
this it's like in the old um Judge Judy
show she said oh no no no no no
no let me get in a word
here yeah something's not adding up
Laura if if Nikki Haley were a plaintiff
in her courtroom she would rule for the
defendant I mean it was clear from her
face but it's not just Judge Judy Beyond
his words of support for Nikki Haley New
Hampshire Governor Chris sonunu also
seems to be having some second thoughts
not long ago he said she was going to
win the primary by a landslide then he
said she'd come in second and that would
be great but look at his face as she
speaks this is a Grassroots Network
they're picking one Democrat donor but
they're not looking at all of them I
will tell you the number one Focus we
have and this is the a problem with the
Republican party now they want to go and
push everybody away that doesn't fit
their
narrative what you love to see the
thought bubble above their heads Laura
no Raven you know what I'm you know what
he you could tell what he was thinking I
think he's thinking what oh my God I
could have done this so much better I
should have run I should have he's like
oh my God am I really standing here he's
like oh wait a second what happened am I
really standing here it's like he's
awakened from a bad dream he's like
looking going what well as they see
Trump continuing to rise which no one
expected here and and you know and you
see everybody getting wobbly it's a bad
look for the governor I mean he chose
the wrong horse hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else